simone veil a précisément fait du
logement social l'un des trois volets de
son plan contre l'exclusion qu'elle a
présenté aujourd'hui aux associations un
accueil pour l'instant plutôt positif
même si la méfiance reste de mise
tirez kurt et et alain poirier ont suivi
toute la journée le ministre des
affaires sociales un ministre d'état à
la rencontre des sdf deux mondes qui
l'espace d'une journée vont se croiser
de parler ici les exclus se sont fédérés
autour d'un projet économique
un journal la rue il est vendu 10 francs
sur le paf et nous leur laisse 7 francs
80 par numéro pas loin de 5000 francs
par mois ce journal se qualifie lui-même
d' entreprise de réinsertion critères de
recrutement
la grande difficulté une notion qui n'a
rien d'administrative une bonne au
travail à ceux qui essaient de s'en
sortir qui s'accroche mais le problème
numéro un de ceux qui n'ont plus rien
reste le logement
simone veil a commencé sa journée dans
ce foyer constat la déchéance arrive
toujours de la même façon
gt gt verrez pas le faire parce que
manger les problèmes de loyer savoir que
j'ai perdu mon travail certes notre
travail plus d'aisé d'épuiser perte du
logement
juste avant que simone veil n'arrive la
plupart des locataires sont partis de ce
foyer
ils avaient peur d'être filmé et
photographié pour la plupart leur
famille n'est pas au courant
le plan de simone veil pour passer
l'hiver 140 millions de francs soit près
de 100 millions de plus que l'année
dernière parce qu'il y a de plus en plus
de gens au bout du chômage il faut aller
vers eux en fait dans les villes puisque
c'est dans certaines villes par
seulement que ce problème se pose il
faut qu'il y ait des bus qui a dit sky
dans tous les quartiers où c'est pour
les sdf quelquefois se retrouvent soit
parce qu'il ya ce soit soit pas se payer
les bouches de métro et que c'est plus
avec frère sociaux les incite à venir
accepter de se faire l'objet ne valent
pas toujours il faut aller vers eux et
c'est le plus difficile car en dehors
des circuits il n'y a plus
d'informations cet hiver il leur
apportant 15 mille lits d'urgence
en tout plus de 60000 places des
boutiques solidarité un samu social
mais s'il y aura malgré tout des gens
qui dormiront dehors car ces aides ne
remplace pas un travail et un foyer